[Music]
hello and welcome to the session on
DevOps environment in various
organizations that adopt DevOps as a
software development and delivery
methodology we will look at how
organizations should set up a DevOps
environment in terms of technologies
tools and also for their teams
culturally what changes they should
bring within the organization to have a
successful DevOps transition and what
are the various challenges that
organizations can run into when bringing
about these DevOps environment changes
for an organization DevOps adoption not
only means a lot of tools and software
for the team to learn and understand of
course that is there it also does not
mean you begin to do your deployments in
a cloud environment that is just one
part of adopting DevOps DevOps option
not only means that you do your
deployments in a docker containers
certainly that is one way of doing your
development and deployment and DevOps
and adoption not only means that your
dev and operations now collaborate
better of course all of that is required
for you to be technology upgraded and
tools upgraded however apart from this
there are a lot of cultural changes
within the organization within the
entire organization and not just the
development teams and your operation
teams to understand this better it is
important to learn that DevOps isn't
something you do it is something that
you believe as an organization which in
turn drives you to do things that drive
your core business if you believe
following DevOps tools following DevOps
best practices will give a boost to your
business will impact your return on
investment would affect your bottom line
then that is how you begin to do things
DevOps is a very different philosophy
than how we used to do projects earlier
in the past QA and operation were
usually separate teams from the
development team within the IT code
would go from a developer to QA and back
and forth till QA passed all the tests
and then operation worked on deploying
the code the intent of having these
gates between different roads was
basically to make sure that nobody did
anything that wasn't supposed to be done
like deploying an unapproved or untested
code into production while this was
implemented or put in place with all the
good intent the end result of this led
to developers becoming lazy knowing that
another team which is the QA team is now
going to check their work so they
concentrated less and less on producing
quality code because they knew even if
they missed something or if they poorly
coded something there is an entire team
dedicated to find any mistakes they did
even while doing unit testing many times
a developer would not even do unit
testing just push the code in the
testing knowing that there are hundreds
of test cases that are going to run so
invariably if they made any mistake it
will get caught
QA intern had to start taking their job
more seriously an organization started
to invest heavily in QA automation
because they not only had to do the
functional testing but many ways they
had to even find falls within the unit
testing or any poorly coded coding
projects that the developers had
followed since the developers were doing
their job less well the organization had
to spend a lot of time and money on
testing this also led to the developer
versus QA approach not being very
beneficial for end software quality
because if there are fundamental issues
with the code written how much ever you
can test you will not be able to find
out all the issues and resolve them in
the time that you have for your project
to be completed and also be able to
produce a quality deliverable
unfortunately the organization's
compensation and reward systems also
heavily supported this approach and this
also led to enter team rivalry making
for a very
unpleasant and unproductive workspace
operation in turn made mistakes because
they did not write the code developers
were laid back and had little motivation
to write code that was easy to deploy
manage or monitor developers basically
threw the code over the wall and then
operations just had to deal with it
this calls further inter team rivalry
between development and operations team
because everyone in the organization was
appraised on the project delivery and
how quickly they were able to deliver it
and how few issues there were so more
issues more problems by operations men
their appraisals were not good and
developers had little reason to start
writing better code because QA was being
questioned for not doing sufficient
testing before the project release went
for production deployment
software development and delivery teams
were all responsible to have the same
goal delivering high quality software
and services to your end customer so we
are all supposed to be in this together
all the teams your business your
development your testing your operations
your stakeholders it is not a matter of
throwing things over the wall and
dusting your hands off that my job is
done so now it is all up to you to know
how to take it into production
DevOps on the other hand envisions
application and software delivery that
can be constantly pushed in small
incremental updates to the end-users
with minimum of operational overhead
small releases are not only easier to
code and test but also far safer to push
into production on an ongoing basis but
in order for all of that to happen
everyone has to work together in a
DevOps environment this is how things
work developers write the code they
check their code into a source code
repository repositories current code is
pooled and built into a software
application all the automated tests
created by developers are run including
integration tests and even user
acceptance test if tests succeed then
the build gets deployed automatically
into production and your end user
feedback is collected which goes into
the next iteration of the development
cycle and you go on repeating these
steps so on and so forth
in a DevOps environment many parts of
this can be automated all these steps
that we just saw parts like user
acceptance testing can perhaps still be
done manually the objective here is to
create as few barriers as possible
between the developer and the end user
that certainly does not mean there are
no checks that is where testing comes in
however you don't put one part of the IT
team in charge of stopping another part
of the IT team from doing stupid things
you need the ability to automatically
and constantly spin up software
environments creating a variety of
authorized roles within your development
team to start environments on-demand it
could be a developer spinning up a
development test environment several
times during the day environments that
are spun up must reflect the final
production environment if you as an
organization cannot come to terms with
allowing your developers to automate
this process then DevOps is something
that you are still not ready for
Neuer configuration management tools
like your microsoft's desired state
configuration chef salt puppet and
ansible let you do all of this
containerization is another technology
that can work as it abstracts a number
of environment variables reducing
variations and complexity between
environments by doing this any
environment whether you are development
test or production the application runs
exactly the same all the time you are
much less likely to run into problems
moving the code from one environment to
another if by adopting all this
automation and tooling you are still
making one team a bottleneck to move
from one step of checking in your code
into source code repository to
triggering a build on that and that
really doesn't help you with the
automation because now you have an away
created manual hurdles or team hurdles
just to trigger these automated tasks
you need to provide developers with a
managed set of capabilities developers
working on a project should be able to
spin up a virtual environment without
anyone else's intervention they should
be able to recycle environments even
delete and recreate anytime they want
they do not get to change their
environment specifications on their own
or get free rein of yet to be created
virtualization infrastructure so these
could be some of the very fundamental
changes that you also need to implement
on the ground when adopting DevOps to
build an environment of your people of
your team's that can support DevOps
you need to have the confidence and
trust in your teams to allow them to do
all of these automated tasks if Trust is
an issue or the capabilities of your
team members is an issue then you have a
separate problem that needs to be solved
but without all this going hand in hand
with latest tools and technology you
will not be able to benefit from DevOps
only as much you will unfortunately not
be able to get the full benefit of
adopting DevOps
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here